today we're going to be speaking with
Alana Newhouse who's the founder and
editor-in-chief of tablet magazine we're
going to be talking about a term
brokenism which I think is super
interesting and it sort of puts a
different perspective on what you know
maybe Alana in our program we often see
as like a left right political divide
only and that's the analysis we make and
we sort of don't go any further you talk
about brokenism and Status quoism talk a
little bit about how you first thought
of this framework and what you mean by
it
um sure so uh two years ago I wrote a
piece
um called Everything Is Broken
um in it I try to articulate what felt
to me like an experience that not only I
was having but a lot of my readers were
having or a lot of people who I knew
were having which was the sense that a
lot of the institutions in American life
and society that we have to interact
with whether that's our kids schools or
our health insurance companies
um with or the IRS felt like they were
not functioning properly they felt
broken
um in the wake of that piece I got a
tremendous response to it it was really
incredibly gratifying and one of the
greatest parts of it was that I ended up
getting emails from a bunch of people
who became regular correspondents with
me
and one of them became a friend and his
name is Ryan and I talk about this in
the beginning of the follow-up essay on
brokenism where at One Moment Ryan
looked at me and said you know I don't
even know what I am I don't know if I'm
a Republican or a Democrat or if I'm a
liberal or conservative all I know is
that I believe in Europe in the basic
premise of your peace which is that
things feel broken and so I guess I
believe in Brokenness
and that kind of
um articulated an idea for me that I
thought
was
very clarifying because it felt to me
like that actually was a thing that
people believed from all over the
Spectrum
um and so it I tried to write a second
piece that articulated what I thought a
Brokenness perspective on the world
um entailed you know sometimes when I'll
have a more detailed conversation with
folks who have this general idea that
there's a lot of things that aren't
working but they might identify as being
on the political left or on the
political right one of the things I've
experienced is that when you really get
details from them about what are the
ways in which some of these systems
aren't working and what's your instinct
about the solution it seems to align
much more closely with what we would be
considered a left-wing View
at now that may be my bias in who I'm
talking to but very often it will be the
the Revelation I have that there's a lot
of discontent with many systems but a
lot of people don't seem to realize that
the solutions they are gravitating
towards are actually more aligned with
one side of political Spectrum than the
other and that's sort of like a concern
to me that people are aren't
acknowledging that do do you experience
the same thing when you talk to some of
these folks or is my view maybe partial
or biased
um what I I think I probably experienced
something a little different from you
but what I guess I would say is is that
one of the things that people talk to me
about is not only the solutions that
they're looking for but also the
diagnosis of the problem and if if in a
funny way if I could say
um what I think might be the case even
maybe for the people that you're talking
to yes is that the solutions that
they're grasping for no matter what part
of the spectrum they come from end up
being solutions that word be associated
with the left but the diagnosis of the
problem
sounds a lot like people from the right
and that's also interesting right
because then we can have a conversation
that can be generative where we can say
oh okay so maybe I come from the left
but I can talk to somebody from the
right because actually what we could
agree on is what's causing some of these
problems even if what we just even if we
disagree on how we would what we would
do to replace them
and that to me part of the reason why I
set out this different way of seeing
things is because also I was trying to
get people out of their entrenched teams
and get them talking to each other and
finding the
um the areas of the landscape on which
they might agree
one of the things that I've experienced
at the anecdotal personal level when
interviewing former extremists like KKK
Neo-Nazi types Etc is that they all tell
a very similar story of the
circumstances that made them vulnerable
to getting pulled into these movements
in the first place and it's a lot of
things that weren't working there's a
lot of broken things that that were
going on is this a bro I mean not
everybody becomes a KKK member obviously
or a Neo-Nazi but there seems to be a
radicalizing effect of a lot of these
things that just aren't working for
people is that accurate
um I think it is um and I think the
people who study extremism might find uh
overlapping themes or uh
events in um in some of what I write
about
um and you know it's part of what's a
challenge here is
a friend of mine actually wrote and said
you know Alana I sort of agree with you
I see what you're saying but I mean come
on is it really mono causal why how did
all of these institutions get broken at
the same time how is that even possible
so many of them have started at
different times
and so of course the answer is quite
clear which is technology like we did
have one thing happen
um and if you actually look back to the
Industrial Revolution
this exact same thing happened in
society
when you have an economic Revolution
that changes the means of how we live
it then comprehensively almost in a
Cascade changes all parts of life it
changes religion communication uh the
Postal Service like it changes
everything and as a result we have to
adjust I think the same thing is
happening now these Institute all of our
institutions were faced with the
challenge of needing to embrace and
adjust themselves to new technologies
some of them adjusted better than others
and some of them are breaking under the
pressure
yeah Neil Postman wrote quite a bit
about this in his books uh technopoly
and then also amusing ourselves to death
and there's a sort of structural
argument there about you know in
linguistics there's this idea it's not I
don't know that it's completely
universally accepted but it's it's much
explored that the language you speak
actually impacts your world view to some
degree based both on a combination of
syntax and the culture surrounding it
and the vocabulary the technologies that
we have including social media or
television or whatever actually are
deterministic to some degree about what
issues make it into the news media or
how do we approach problems or whatever
the case may be it's that sort of
argument that would explain the timing I
think of what you're talking about
yes
absolutely
so Neil Postman would say there's really
no going back and it's about how do you
try to regulate in order to harness the
parts we want but to limit the parts
that don't work so well when we think
about Solutions do you agree with that
yes I think that part of the um you know
in this interview I've talked a lot
about the Brokenness perspective but
part of what I try to do with the essay
was also articulate the other
perspective the sort of Warring
perspective which I also find incredibly
compelling which is the belief in what's
what exists and the belief that what
exists may or may not need some
reforming or need some tweaking but that
you simply don't throw whole
institutions or systems out the window
especially when those systems
um are
are the the basket for people's needs
um sometimes in their safety and their
livelihoods
um
status quoes believe that we need to
work very very hard at fixing our
current institutions
in a way there's a I think an incredibly
inspiring and exciting conversation to
be had if you put those two groups
together because what you get is you say
oh how about instead of fighting
and trying to convince each other to
join sides we're not going to join what
if together we look at the landscape and
we almost assess like do a do an
assessment and say what are the
institutions that need reforming what
are the institutions that need radical
reforming and what are the institutions
that need complete replacement
and let everyone do their part let the
Brokenness look at something and say
this is broken I'm burning it to the
grounds and I'm starting again
and let the status quoests reform what
might actually be salvageable the the
difficulty in that as great as it sounds
is that there is a big divide about
what's worthy of totally being destroyed
and starting from scratch and what needs
to be reforming you mentioned education
last week in a 48-hour period you had
Candace Owens saying the solution to the
U.S being poor at math is breeding for
math skills like the South Koreans do
and then two days later at CPAC she says
we should get rid of the Department of
Education it's like you don't need to
breed you need to teach we have but they
want to but on the left I think we would
not say we need to get rid of the
Department of Education so it seems that
the disagreement would come in which of
which institutions fall under which of
the two categories
right and look
into create conversation with or people
who are political repetitions uh that's
a challenge that's very different from
my own right I'm actually looking to
create to generate a conversation that
feels fruitful among
at regular people okay and people who
actually are uh maybe uh people who
belong to the same town right
um but who feel differently about the
solutions or differently about the
institutions of their world and they're
invested at a personal and granular
level in those institutions and they are
not grandstanders who are just looking
to make broad points these are people
who actually want to get their hands
dirty they just don't know in what way
they don't know if they're if they want
to get their hands dirty by
completely abandoning their local school
district
because it's become too corrupt right or
by reforming it getting different people
on the board and those are to me those
are decisions that actually do have to
get made at a local level and do have to
get made person by person town by town
community by community
and then I think it generates
friends nationally and maybe even
internationally
super super interesting we've been
speaking with Alana Newhouse who's the
founder and editor-in-chief of tablet
magazine and we'll link to the articles
that we've been sort of talking about in
this conversation Alana really
appreciate your time and insights
thanks so much for having me